[Musique]
kevin gardien je suis chef de
l'orangerie du château à bord ça fait un
an que je travaille ici en tant que chef
sam à un restaurant gastronomique depuis
à peu près une vingtaine d'années
mon plus beau souvenir l'obtention de la
deuxième étoile à dijon au restaurant
william frachot voilà on était une belle
équipe et on a tous travaillé pour
obtenir cette récompense
donc ça a été vraiment un très gros
souvenir de décrocher cette deuxième
étoile
aujourd'hui nous allons réaliser la
recette de céleri cuit à la braise et
truffes de soleil donc on va cuire un
céleri entier au barbecue directement
dans la braise ce qui va lui permettre
de rester cuir sans sono savent
accueillir donner du goût un petit goût
fumé avec ceux ci on va préparer une
petite purée de céleri aussi donc là une
fois qu'on a lancé la purée d'apurer la
en train de cuire ont racheté un petit
bouillon de feuilles de céleri aussi à
nous que ramener un petit côté arbas et
hop là un petit peu de fraîcheur
on va passer à la crème à la truffe donc
là on va juste avoir besoin des 100 g de
crème du jus de citron et la truffe
[Musique]
donc là voilà on a notre série qui
accueille environ entre 2h30 et 3h on va
l'ouvrir
on va récupérer juste l'intérieur
[Musique]
vincenti de l'est
et là on va pouvoir passer au dressage
donc là on a notre purée de céleri
là on va creuser le céleri on vient de
l'assaisonner avec un tout petit peu
d'huile d'olive et de la flore de cette
[Musique]
norme est juste un peu de très malade
pffff dessus donc là on va répartir un
peu nos lamelles de truffe notre
bouillon de feuilles de céleri vert donc
on a blanchi le mixer
et donc pour finir en quelques points
d'émission de céleri toaster et donc
voici la recette de céleri qu à la
braise et truffes de soleil
[Musique]